okay guess who just got home from a day
at the vet and she got sedated so she is
still a little drugged up this one
thank who's how you doing I'm flying
okay hey baby oh it is so good looking
ears got super clean and gunk in them
well you look you look thin good job
girl oh my god we're all doing this
right now including Shane Dawson hey hey
what are you doing today Shane
I am vlogging with you guys I feel like
a complete so we are about to go ahead
mamrie would you like to explain that so
we're gonna shoot youtube deserve a
drink with Shane and this is the first
time that Shane has ever drank alcohol
I'm taking his [ __ ] virginity
it's this thing right here what is it
memory oh no that's just a separate
cocktail oh that's the horn up we're
gonna cheers and this will be Shane
Dawson's first sip of booze I am Reptar
I'm going to hell I couldn't be happier
cheers cheers Cheers family habits are
gonna to come in okay okay okay take my
food it tastes like not what my grandpa
used to use it kind of reminds me it's
okay it's like an Oreo shake that
somebody spilled like Britney Spears
curious perfume in
[Music]
well okay yeah well welcome friend
oh hello today we're starting our day by
going to the Federal Building to pick up
my passport because tomorrow I leave for
London and that is a crucial element to
me getting to London and I have waited
too long to try and get it so I need it
today we'll see if it's available uh the
federal buildings really fun time like
it's just like been a Jean beige on
beige on beige on beige it's like if if
bread was a building and be the federal
building
[Music]
for this
[Music]
well hello yes I've made it to London
and did this I didn't lite better
I don't know it's like that wasn't in
the video uh we're here in London this
is my room
and I feel like everything is tiny
look this feel like my hand is gonna hit
the top of the doorways
look he's two little hobbit beds Ted
cute so he ordered myself two vodka
sodas and he delivered them and asked if
I wanted these opened and I said no no I
got it
I then don't realize that they're not
there did not screw tap and I don't have
a beer opener so I'm gonna try this
[Music]
I've decided to just drink the vodka by
itself to be quite honest this has been
my London reality writing I'm not
showing you underwriting cuz it's secret
stuff I'm sitting in a bit and writing
and sitting in a bed so really get it
travelling happen like these videos
better to just eat stuff that will make
my body awful is that what you want
YouTube I was gonna jump on the bed to
make things fun but I don't know what
this is I don't think this is gonna work
out I'm gonna go and maimry comes into
town tomorrow and the secret projects
start tomorrow and I'm really excited
and yeah it's gonna be really fun so
next week's friary will be exciting if I
remember to shoot it so sorry this
week's Friday rate I'm not gonna
apologize
dudes do and stuff it's dudes dudes day
[Applause]
it's doing stuff it's dudes do we start
these to look at these terror and love a
shooting top-secret project yeah
[Music]